episode 8 of what if is now out and the
penultimate entry is filled with easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed in this breakdown we're going to
be giving a big recap of the entire
thing before going into what could be
happening in the finale next week now
what is a spoiler-filled breakdown if
not just a spoiler free one persevering
i really don't know but if you haven't
had a chance to check out the episode
then i suggest you check out now make
sure you like the video and also
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss next week's breakdown as we will of
course be talking about the finale
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into what if episode
8. okay so last week's episode ended
with the biggest party pooper of them
all arriving on the scene ultron had
entered party thor's universe and with
him he brought not only his iron legion
of ultron bots but also the infinity
stones and visions face i forgot to
point out last time that the way the
mask opened up was clearly a naughty
tony stark's iron man one in reverse
tony of course helped to build ultron in
the mcu and because of this the murder
bot took on several of his personality
traits these included his speech
patterns and sayings and one of them
even triggered claw into realizing who
made him however it actually went far
beyond that and in the movie both the
characters struggled over the word
children invaders create avengers
people create
smaller people
[Music]
children have lost the word there
hey
i absolutely love this detail and the
episode should sort of be seen as
visions revenge for all those times that
he died which which was a lot it was a
lot to be fair
now the episode basically reframes
avengers age of ultron and asks us what
would have happened had ultron won in
the film he attempted to shift his
consciousness into vision's body and had
he achieved this then the character
would have been almost indestructible
whilst there are several callbacks to
that film there's also some nods to one
division and other movies involving
killer machines when ultron awakens in
vision's body the shot is actually set
up to look very similar to one hayward
activated white vision at the end of one
division episode 8. beyond that i got a
lot of terminator vibes and that
franchise is of course about an ai that
ends up going rogue and it destroys all
of humanity when the needs are firing we
can catch several shots including a form
in which the weapons are launched close
to as well as the planet from space as
the explosions go off similar sort of
scenes happened in terminator 3 i think
it might be a call back to that now the
episode as a whole is also basically
taking the concept of the original age
of ultron comic and going completely
wild with it in that ultron destroyed
the world and the heroes had to band
together in order to stop him characters
like hawkeye even retreated to bunkers
and they fought on the landscape of a
destroyed planet which included
locations like new york and san
francisco
unlike the episode wolverine ended up
going back in time and stopping things
but i really feel like they gave us the
age of ultron that we as fans wanted the
movie was very much in name only and
it's nice that they found a way to give
fans of the book something that falls in
line with what many of us thought the
film would be about now we start with
the watcher overlooking a completely
devastated landscape covered in what
likely is the fallout of nuclear winter
we see natasha romanov racing in on her
bike and also catch clint with a metal
arm similar to the winter soldiers his
arm was clearly taken from him in a
tactical way so that he couldn't fire
arrows but he's managed to regain the
ability due to the synthetic this is a
slight switch-up from the comics as in
that when we joined black widow she was
with moon knight instead of hawkeye he
however did open the series so it's nice
they've managed to keep the character
structure somewhat similar that is
desperate to outrun the machines as they
chase her through the city and it's not
too long before they pick up hawkeye who
must have stole an invisible cloak from
harry potter hawkeye now has his mohawk
back like he did between the snap in the
blip in avengers endgame this was at a
time when he lost everything including
his family so it's nice that they
brought it back because of the symbolism
it carries now at the time yeah at the
time i came up with a bloody great
nickname for him and that was mo hawkeye
but it never caught on however i'm
bringing it back and calling myself an
underappreciated genius because mo
hawkeye is absolutely amazing and you
better like that you better like the
bloody video i'll tell you the fight
scene is extremely similar to his one
against the chittori and the avengers
and it's easily the best opening of the
series for me the ultron bots leave
hawkeye looking pretty armless but you
have to hand it to him the guy does some
great falling with style throughout the
scene widow mentions the hive mind and
this is also somewhat a nod to the
original graphic novel in that our
heroes learned that ultron had actually
traveled into the future and that he was
using vision's body as a conduit in the
past to make sure that they had no
chance of winning because vision came
from ultron it granted him the ability
to possess him and the episode somewhat
does something similar with the mcu
counterpart now it turns out that the
pair have gone to the kremlin which
natasha refers to his home black widow
is of course russian and this infamous
location is of course in moscow we then
go to the past and see tony saying that
he sees a suit of armor around the world
whilst looking over loki's scepter this
of course contained the mind stone and
it allowed tony to create what he
believed was a peacekeeping program tony
did a full u-turn on his original
ideology as you might remember that he
initially said he'd be out of the job
with peace however this changed over the
series and upon leaving the cave the
first thing he did was hold up a peace
sign in the senate he held up two and
upon burying the hatchet with captain
america he said he just wanted peace the
idea to create peace in our time made
him build ultron which was of course his
greatest failure i think it says a lot
about humanity that ultron spent 30
seconds on the internet and just thought
you know what these guys gotta go now in
the intro we get several shots of age of
ultron including the one in which they
stood around vision's cradle unit
deciding what to do with it however in
the multiverse ultron was able to upload
successfully and thus he was near
unstoppable ultron went after the new
codes and completely decimated the
avengers because of his new abilities we
catch a quick cut of capped shield
completely destroyed on the floor and
this is something that was seen in
tony's vision at the start of age of
ultron we also catch similar iconography
to this vision including a slumped over
hulk and milner also on the ground now i
believe that this is located at the
nexus point which we learned in that
film was the central hub in which all
information on the internet flowed
through this included the nuclear codes
which ultron gets his hands on general
ross looks over the entire destruction
of the planet and nat and clint only
managed to survive because they're in a
quinjet when it happens i've seen a
couple of people asking why it's got a
similar voice to james spader and not
paul bettany well this is because that
voice very much came from jarvis but as
ultron's the dominating personality here
this version ends up sticking with the
original sound in the end after bringing
peace to the world we watch as thanos
arrives on earth in order to collect the
mind stone his entrance is very similar
to how he appeared on titan and infinity
war but he doesn't really get the same
welcome and instead he's immediately cut
in two which was quite funny in the wide
shot we can see that ultron's now made
his home at avengers tower and in age of
ultron we saw as a quinjet runway had
been put in place to allow easier access
for the avengers vision destroys the
gauntlet and using what i believe on
nano machines he makes himself into a
living one this could be a nod to the
comics as in that tony made a suit
capable of holding the stones but it
could also be a reach now because of his
newfound gifts he's able to alter
reality and create as many ultron
sentries as he wants it's at this point
that he manifests a red cape and now he
had one as the vision this could be a
nod to the scene in which viz mimicked
thor and created one for himself from
this point onwards he travels across the
galaxy independent staying everything
and his first stop is asgard there's a
shot in here that i think could be a
reference to alien covenant namely the
ozymandia scene in which david arrives
on the engineer's home planet and
completely destroys it next he travels
to the sovereign which is where we see
the events from the opening of guardians
of the galaxy vol 2. originally that was
quite a fun scene packed with baby groot
dancing but here it's absolutely
devastating we watch as he travels to
sakaar and see the midst of a gladiator
battle and get not only an appearance by
korg but also the grand master now the
grandmaster's smile has been completely
wiped off his face and he dies in a
manner that looks very similar to lara's
death at the beginning of man of steel
yes i know it's dc and not marvel i'm
just saying now ego gets his shut down
as the planet is annihilated and the
zandarians are decimated captain marvel
arrives and calls him skynet which is of
course a nod to the ai from terminator
she says she doesn't think that film
needs a sequel and this is because she
had left earth when terminator 2 was
made so she wouldn't know it existed
maybe she was right though yeah because
some of those terminator sequels not
very good now carol flies him into the
planet's core and though she almost
destroys him ultron bests her with a
combined might of the infinity stones
destroying her completely ravages the
galaxy and it is possible that this
explosion happens because carol herself
has powers which come from an infinity
stone the combined might of this
destroys life as we know it except for
on earth weirdly but rather than finding
joy in completing his task much like
thanos there is some sadness to it the
work is done but it has robbed him of
his purpose and because of the silence
in the universe he's able to attain
another level of consciousness which
allows him to witness the watcher this
alerts him to the fact that there are
universes and it just continues his path
of genocide now the watcher has been a
character that's appeared in all of the
episodes so far and throughout our
videos we theorized that he was gonna be
the one that pulled all of the heroes
together for the finale throughout the
series you might have noticed that he's
been getting closer and closer and
closer every single time first he
started off as just a silhouette amongst
the stars but as the episodes have gone
on we've started to be able to see the
actual details in his face because he
was close up and personal in episode 5
and then took a big step back for six
before going even further back for seven
we did theorize that the leaks were true
and that the order of five and seven had
been switched if we look at them in the
leaked order i think it does line up and
it is possible that the creative team
swapped the episodes so we got the tease
of ultron last week now for me the way
they've done it works a lot better than
what they had in the leaks and though
we'll probably never know for definite
if that's what happened i do think that
the leaked episode lineup was indeed
true
and that's because i'm never ever gonna
admit i'm wrong i'm never admitting it
never now we join up with widow and
hawkeye once more and they travel into
the final storage center of the kremlin
hawkeye asks if nada's seen raiders of
the lost ark and this shot is very
similar to the one at the end of that
movie i wish they had have said do you
get the feeling we're being watched but
alas they get down to the busy work and
attempt to go through the files one by
one within them widow finds red
guardian's shield and she ends up taking
it the watcher also gets a bit bored and
frustrated like when you watch your
friend play a video game and he starts
shouting out that the key lies with
arnhem zola who has of course appeared
in the mcu at several points in the
winter soldier we learn that he became
an ai after uploading his brain today at
banks below camp lehigh he's the only
thing that can really combat ultron and
we learn that there's a copy of him at a
hydra base in siberia now because of
this it is possible that he still exists
in the mcu and dun dun dun i'm gonna say
zola is still alive now i would
absolutely love to see him back in the
marvel universe especially if they gave
him his robot body from the comics and
this does sort of highlight that there
is a way to bring him back now he does
get somewhat of a robot body later on in
the episode but hopefully this isn't the
last time that we've seen him and yeah
just bring the guy back now the watcher
ways are whether to intervene as this
would of course have disastrous
consequences at the end of the episode
he does and it is possible that this
just causes more breaks in the
multiverse
which could lead into season two now
when clint gives up he says the death
star plans are not in the main computer
and this line is pulled verbatim from
the opening of a new hope when a
stormtrooper said it to darth vader
clint has given up help but the location
to zola is found by nat and they head
out to the base this base in siberia was
also the location that we saw at the
start of civil war and it's where the
winter soldier program operated out of
unfortunately at this point ultron
breaks through the multiversal barrier
and he states that destroying this is
his purpose which may be another agent
smith who said the phrase repeatedly in
the matrix trilogy in the hub they find
the winter soldier tanks that were used
to house the other agents and as we saw
in that film zemo killed them all they
activate zola who states their names
upon greeting them and this is similar
to what he did in the winter soldier you
might also notice that the instructions
to activate him are in russian whereas
in america they were in english he goes
to rattle the speech off that he gave in
that movie but nat shuts it down after
saying that she's already made a copy of
him hawkeye threatens to wicked witch of
the west him and pour water all over his
computer and thus he agrees to their
demands they call in the cavalry and
order a pizza from ultron which alerts
them to their presence it only takes a
couple of minutes for them to deliver it
and i tell you what peter parker he's
not going to be happy about that now
hawkeye uses a usb type arrow and the
character also had something similar in
the avengers when he launched his attack
on the helicarrier this idea of
uploading a virus to ultron actually
pulls directly from the comics as in age
of wolverine traveled into the past and
told hank to put one in place so that
should the day come when ultron goes
wild that they'd have a way to stop him
zola says ultron isn't the first
genocidal maniac he's had to deal with
and this is of course not only a nod to
hitler but also the red skull they
destroy the data banks and fire an arrow
into a sentry which allows zola to
infect it they then travel into a
similar rocket area to what tony cap and
bucky fought in during civil war and it
leads to a great action scene in which
they go head-to-head with the horde of
ultron bots intent on their destruction
in a reverse of avengers endgame clint
is the one who ends up falling instead
of widow and the pair holding onto each
other's arms i think is definitely put
in place to mirror the scene in which
nat dies in a reverse of it clint is the
one who sacrifices himself and we
learned that because ultron has traveled
into the multiverse that zola is unable
to disable him on the outside of reality
he and the watcher go head-to-head
across the landscape of the multiverse
which does look similar to the area that
we saw in the hyundai ad that i'll talk
about later on uh manifests his own
armor and the two battle it out which
not only shows how powerful the ladder
is but also how powerful that ultra now
is because of the infinity stones he's
able to destroy any reality at will and
we watch as they travel from universe to
universe you might notice that the guy
from last week who had pineapples on his
shirt is back and it seems like his
destiny is to be at the forefront of
every alien invasion on a times square
billboard we can actually catch steve in
the background being sworn in as the
president and this is one of the best
easter eggs i think has been in the show
so far as ultron punches him reality
warps around them and we watch as the
onlookers transform into a condens
before they become people from the
middle ages and also scrolls it really
sets up infinite ultron as the most
dangerous threat in the entire
multiverse and it's difficult to think
if we've encountered someone worse than
this kurta the watcher going to strange
supreme's home in which he too destroyed
reality we see him in his beast form but
he does turn back into a human in order
to talk to yuatu he's as arrogant as
ever and he rubs it in the watch's face
that he's gonna have to break his oath
similar to the watcher strange took an
oath namely the hippocratic one in which
he said he'd never take a life however
this version ended up breaking that and
they do share some common ground and you
know you have to do what you want to do
oh so bad sorry i was just in ejecting
that i was gonna do a you do want to
break your oath but let's be honest both
those puns are as bad as each other now
he asks for help yeah how we close out
in a similar manner to what we did in
the strange supreme episode with us
seeing his gem-like reality
now as for next time there has been a
lot of the finale that's been shown in
the trailers weirdly there's actually
more out on that episode than there was
in advance for this one and we will of
course be getting a massive team up with
all of the heroes from across the series
marvel are so smart in the way that they
do team ups and they've kind of done
what if in the exact same way that they
did the avengers they seemingly did
standalone stories that gave us all of
the origins of the characters but we now
know that they're gonna team up and it
just allows us to hit the ground running
next week now so far on the sneak peeks
and first looks we've seen several
meetings including captain carter coming
face to face with strange supreme there
was also him meeting with thor and the
ladder talked about zombies which of
course ties in with episode 5. there's
been two big team-up shots shown in the
trailers and this included black widow
captain carter fenora and party thor the
pan is pretty quick on it in the
trailers but we can also catch to
charlotte standing there as well also
did you catch that captain carter has an
updated uniform the union jack on her
chest appears silver much in the same
way that cap starters too darn it make
it bloody proud to be british now the
other team up shot had killmonger in his
black panther costume thenora again this
time a better view of t'challa and
lastly party thought so yeah the
trailers spoiled it all before i even
had a chance to you might also remember
that there was a hyundai ad in which
several of the characters from the
series fought against ultron bots and
this is probably going to be similar to
what we see in the final episode with
the amazing new hyundai hopefully making
an appearance available now available
now go buy one now in that ad the
watcher also used his powers and i have
a theory that his interfering to stop
this big threat actually causes the
multiverse to split even more and that
this sets up season 2. there was also a
clip in the first trailer in which party
thor said slow down as there's people in
the room that don't understand what
you're saying though he said it wasn't
him and he got the gist of it he was
clearly talking about himself because
yeah the guy's a bit dim no offense if
he's watching this which he probably is
he's a big fan now not only does this
kind of show that the over-the-top
arrogance and vanity that this version
of thor has but it also lets us know
that something quite complicated is
being explained to a room full of people
my guess is that this is either the
watcher or strange supreme going over
the multiverse to the heroes that have
been pulled across they'll probably be
explaining this matinee threat and it's
all just going over thor's head now this
will probably be earlier in the episode
i imagine and it'll help to get the
heroes up to speed before they go into a
big fight it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens and because they're
multiversal versions there might even be
a couple of deaths there was also a shot
in which pepper and a young shuri were
fighting in what i believe is wakanda as
well as one of ego holding quill up in
the air to drain his powers this makes
me think that we might also get some
parts early on in the episode in which
we learn about what happened in the
cliffhangers in the series the charlotte
fighting across the multiverse and not
being there to stop ego could lead to
that reality being destroyed but yet
we're just gonna have to see
now for the next part of the video i'm
gonna be giving a brief review and then
going into the venom let there be
carnage post credit scene details that
i've been told i will give you a heads
up before then though in case you want
to dive out the video without having
anything ruined now as for my thoughts
on the episode i know this was another
pretty depressing one but if you've been
keeping up with our reviews then you'll
know dems are favorite for me this is
one of the best episodes in the entire
series if not the best and i'm gonna
have to go back and rewatch the strange
supreme one and zombies alongside this
to decide which is my favorite it also
answers a big criticism that people have
with the show which is that everything
feels disjointed as i mentioned marvel
are just sticking to the strategy of
letting us get to know the characters
before they bring them all together and
it's nice that we now know that this is
where they're taking things it looks
like they're doing the same thing with
either the dark avengers or thunderbolts
and it just works really well in my
opinion the finale will be way better
because we've had this setup and i
actually think that the series will work
really well on re-watches because
they've took the time to lay the
groundwork anyway great little
depressing episode which is always fun
fun fun for me now as for the venom
leaks full spoilers ahead and there'll
be carnage in the comments if i don't
give you this heads up so head off now
okay so the post credit scene of venom
let there be carnage will apparently
show the peter parker news report that
was shown at the end of far from home we
catch eddie brock and venom in a hotel
room watching it and when peter parker
appears on screen the ladder says he
looks tasty i haven't got many details
beyond the pair just being sat watching
it play out but that's meant to be
what's going on from what i've been told
that awesome indicators that this could
be happening in the multiverse with
venom being pulled across but i don't
know for definite however that is very
interesting potentially he could have
been pulled into the mcu timeline or he
could just be seeing things from his own
universe details are super sketchy at
the moment but that's what's currently
going round about the ending of the film
there was a fan screening of the movie
earlier this month which tom hardy said
not to spoil but then the marketing team
at sony just kept saying things like the
universe is expanding and so on so yeah
you kind of spoiled it yourself now from
what i've been told venom won't actually
feature in no way home and instead
daniel rpk has reported that spider-man
will be the one who shows up in venom
three take all this with a pinch of salt
as leaks and reports like this can
always just be made up but that seems to
be what's happening anyway that's the
video on the episode and i hope you
enjoyed it and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts and theories on
everything that we've talked about we
are running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of last week's episode of what
if or whatever the hell i've put on
screen right now don't know as a record
beforehand but yeah you'll you'll love
it i promise mate if not then uh thanks
for sitting through this part of the
video i don't know why you're still here
go enjoy the rest of your day take care
yourself peace
you